los prisioneros rusos quieren volver a
casa capturados por las fuerzas
ucranianas al principio de la ofensiva
en febrero ahora encarcelados en kiev
esperan con ansias el momento de ser
intercambiados y devueltos a su país
el 23 de febrero por la noche se recibió
una orden nos armamos nos sentamos con
el equipo militar y cruzamos la frontera
en un pequeño destacamento soy el jefe
de la radio estaba a cargo de las
comunicaciones en algún lugar de la zona
de chernin no sé qué asentamientos estén
allí no conozco la zona no se buscaron
el pasado 1 de julio se produjo el mayor
intercambio de prisioneros hasta la
fecha entre ambas naciones pero algunos
todavía esperan a que llegue su turno se
están produciendo intercambios de
prisioneros y hace tres semanas hubo el
último se intercambiaron 144 por 144
personas
por alguna razón aún no he sido incluido
pero espero que algún día me cambien
para las autoridades ucranianas el
intercambio de prisioneros es también un
tema crucial según su viceministra de
defensa ellos quieren traer de vuelta al
país a personas vulnerables mientras los
rusos dicen están interesados en
reclutar a oficiales
ucrania pretende intercambiar
principalmente a mujeres y heridos con
grados de lesiones importantes
los rusos exigen el intercambio por
otros principios están muy interesados
en reclutar a sus oficiales
independientemente de su condición el
rango militar es muy importante para
ellos está a punto de entrar en el sexto
mes de guerra las negociaciones entre
moscú y kiev avanzan en cuestiones como
las exportaciones de granos pero muchos
prisioneros de guerra continúan a la
espera de soluciones sobre sus condenas